a lot of people have been involved in
this yes some arms were twisted uh yes
some were recalcitrant yes to be frank
some hadn't really thought about it as
hard as they should um but things take
on their own momentum and as i said when
you have leadership of uh institutions
leadership of the prime minister and
others and uh and the chancellor and
helping to get this done uh things
happen
when you talk about hundreds of
trillions of dollars yeah it's quite
hard to wrap your head around that
that's very hard so
where is that money going what is it
being invested in that it perhaps wasn't
before is it being invested in a
different way could you break it down a
little bit so let let's put it into
context uh that total figure 130
trillion dollars so that's all of the
balance sheets all of the assets of
the pension funds the insurers the banks
etc who have signed up for the glasgow
financial alliance for net zero made
these net zero commitments now that's
about 40 percent
two dollars out of every five two pounds
out of every five dollars of financial
assets in the world so it is an absolute
enormous figure what will the
consequences be if someone lags behind
and doesn't do what they promised well
look if it's um if if it if it's
consistent they're not making the effort
um and there and continue to
underperform they they will no longer be
part of the alliance i mean this is an
alliance that is resolutely focused on
net zero are you insisting that as part
of membership of this club
these investment companies banks
pensions and so on
end
any subsidization or investment in
fossil fuel companies well i wouldn't
say any uh financing in fossil fuel
companies to be clear what they've
committed to
is the most rigorous transition that the
scientific community has put out there
which is and i'll be more specific the
iea
one and a half degree transition uh with
no overshoot the the cognizant i will
know exactly what that means there's the
ipc um scenario as well or pathway with
that that's what they're committing to
and so that includes continuing to
invest in fossil fuel companies well
listen hannah you know there is not a
green switch that we can flip this
afternoon and move from being uh
economies where four fifths of global
energy is supplied by fossil fuels today
um and overnight be 100 supplied by
renewables that's not possible but what
is
essential is there's not new investment
in additional capacity
that the world is not going to need